when we look up at the night sky it is
quite easy to believe that space looks
like a serene place
where hardly any dramatic events occur
but if we were to represent the universe
on a large map
it would be possible to see some really
tremendous things
it would really be quite a sight
imagine what this most large-scale
phenomenon in the explored parts of
space would look like
an explosion whose power is comparable
to some global processes in the universe
or a release of energy as powerful as
the hypothetical big bang itself
[Music]
the first in outer space to begin with
let's define what the big bang actually
is and estimate
how much power may have been released in
this process
the concept of the phenomenon referred
to describes the accepted cosmological
model of the genesis and
early life of the universe namely the
beginning of the universe's expansion
after an undefined period of being in
the state of singularity
the state of singularity is the state of
the universe when the density of energy
was large
and the space-time curve was sharp these
figures
reached the planck values the big bang
on the other hand is said to have been
the starting point for the process of
this energy getting released
this event can't have been anything like
a dynamite stick going off an empty
space
besides it took place literally
everywhere at the same time
and it's hardly possible to pinpoint the
epicenter
it is indeed hardly possible to say with
certainty
how it really happened and what it
looked like
but one thing is clear this was an
ultimate event of enormous proportions
we're talking about an explosion that is
considered to have given birth to the
entire universe
in the centuries of the history of space
observation science hasn't registered
any other event similar in its
proportions
however as our technologies became more
advanced
scientists came to realize that there
are some events taking place in deep
space
which are powerful to such a point that
it appears that all existing models
need to be questioned one of these
breakthrough discoveries was gamma ray
bursts
or grbs the term traditionally refers to
large-scale energy emissions in space
which in fact are an everyday occurrence
in the cosmos
gamma ray bursts are the most powerful
of explosions known to science
taking place in space shockingly
the energy released in a few seconds is
tantamount to that released by the sun
in the course of 10 billion years it was
next to impossible to register gamma-ray
bursts for 30 years
even though some attempts revealed a
rather exact location of a source
sources were always scattered and didn't
repeat in one place
a burst didn't leave any traces
whatsoever and the best scientists could
do was to identify some really remote
galaxy where a burst was registered
only in 1968 was it possible for
scientists to put their finger on the
phenomenon of gamma-ray bursts
all thanks to the veiler satellites of
the u.s air force
whose mission was detecting possible
nuclear tests in the atmosphere
according to today's views gamma ray
bursts occur when massive stars go
supernova and collapse to black holes
a powerful stream of charged particles
bursts out from the hill's vicinity
on interacting with magnetic fields and
cosmic radiation
these particles produce gamma rays as a
result
this stream of gamma rays is powerful to
such a point that such events are easily
detected by satellites
even though they may have taken place
several billion light years away
on the other hand they can't be
registered by earth-based telescopes on
account of the atmosphere
which actively absorbs these rays
the amount of energy released in the
course of a gamma-ray burst may reach a
septum decilion ergs
if an event of such tremendous
proportions were to take place close to
a planet
it would be tantamount to an atomic bomb
exploding in every hectare of the sky
of course all living things would almost
certainly die
instantly a gamma ray burst is capable
of exterminating any life within the
radius of tens
and even hundreds of light years and
seriously affecting biospheres of
planets within the radius of thousands
of light-years
thankfully they occur a bigger distance
away from us
for example one of the most powerful
gamma-ray bursts ever detected
dubbed grb180720
is more than 4 billion light years away
from us
this means that its light has traveled
to our earth for about one
third of the universe's age as for the
amount of energy in this gamma-ray burst
it fluctuates between 200 to 1000
billion electron volts
just to compare the energy of visible
light is in the range from 1
to 3 electron volts at a distance of
tens of thousands of light years a gamma
ray burst like that
is practically harmless but one out of a
hundred or thousand flares in a galaxy
may occur close enough to a planet to
pose a threat
speaking about a threat to our own
planet scientists are still at odds if
an explosion like that may dramatically
affect it
for example according to some
calculations
gamma ray bursts are really capable of
seriously and noticeably affecting the
earth's fauna
every several hundred million years and
one of these flares may have been the
cause of a major mass extinction event
however science is more keen on
investigating the nature and origin of
such bursts
today it is posited that as a rule
gamma-ray bursts
occur following the collapse of a really
massive star
or else when two neutron stars merge and
collapse together to a black hole
a gamma-ray burst event doesn't much
differ from a supernova event in this
respect
as both of them involve a gravitational
collapse of a star's core
the difference lies in the consequences
in the case with a star-going supernova
a hard layer of matu's shed which
travels with a speed of 10 to 30
kilometers per second
as for a gamma ray burst something
emitting gamma quanta travels
practically at the speed of light
an event like that isn't likely to occur
anywhere close to us
be it as it may a great number of events
of a similarly large scale
occur in the cosmos and they may well
take place comparatively close to us
one of these could be a star-going
supernova a phenomenon when a star's
apparent magnitude intensifies
10 to 20 times this process is the
ultimate destructive event taking place
at the end of some star's evolution
and is accompanied by the release of
great amounts of energy
a supernova event is accompanied by
emissions of substantial amounts of
matter from the star's outer layer in
interstellar space
if the star's mass before the explosion
was more than eight
sun masses a compact object is formed
from the remaining matter of the star
this object is called a neutron star
if the star's mass was more than 40 sun
masses
it is positive that a black hole appears
after the explosion
as for the composition of these
emissions there's a large percentage of
thermonuclear synthesis products
the remains of the process taking place
throughout the star's entire life cycle
it is thanks to such supernovae that the
universe in general
and every galaxy in particular
chemically evolve
it goes without saying that what i've
told you about the nature of these
events
is largely theoretical assumptions
man hasn't observed these processes from
up close
and therefore cannot make definite
statements about their nature
nevertheless thanks to the development
of astrophysics science is advancing
impressively far ahead
revealing things unheard of in the past
and who knows as time goes by we will
probably get closer to understanding
much
more complex matters
[Music]
you